[Music]
thank you
[Music]
and deer who or what the hell is he in
Deer oh it says Andor well then why the
hell is a Star Wars show being set on a
planet from Star Trek these are not
lightsabers in case you confuse this
with any words that would make sense to
me rocks Grand you don't have to put on
the blue light Those Days Are Over You
don't have to sell your body to a Jedi
Knight also I honestly have no idea what
these individuals are selling but I
simultaneously want all and none of it
excuse me
we were at first yeah we've been waiting
he just got here I know you want me to
hate these two Imperial red shirts so
why are you starting by having them make
so much sense there is an order to lines
an order I say there was a girl from
Canary whose brother was so very sorry
with backstory to tell on his past he
would dwell can we just get to the wars
that are Starry what are you
seriously boyfriend husband
no judgment here my friend but Game of
Thrones really has that corner of the
genre covered what was her name nobody
here gives their real name yes but did
you not think he might want it anyway to
help with the search otherwise she's
assuming that Andor doesn't know his own
sister's name which is possible but
still a weird assumption
how did these guys catch up to him we
know they were looking to get
um served before him so are they done
already even if their Photon Torpedoes
fired a bit early and or would have been
long gone unless I'm overestimating the
power of star boners there's no way they
left early
if nothing else at least this
interaction confirms that a long time
ago definitely predates the book and all
of the oldest tricks it contains this
man has died from a slight reverse
headbutt to the side of the face I'm not
even saying that's impossible I'm just
saying it's lame
[Applause]
damn it Star Wars and or accidentally
kills the thug from the brothel and now
I guess he'll feel obligated to leave
this guy alive because he's the hero or
whatever but this will just cause him
all sorts of trouble when he could
totally get away with murder oh
he straight up murdered him but now who
do I root for damn it Star Wars
[Music]
same but waiting this long to shock the
carillion Hound currently being on you
um Disney you got some Wally in my Star
Wars
we interrupt your prequel series to a
prequel movie to watch this prequel
sequence disguised as a flashback also
through this entire flashbacks position
the subtitles only read speaks qunari
I'm fine without translating everything
into English I think that can be a
useful story device but why not put the
actual qunari words on the screen part
of the beauty of including another
language is the rhythms and sounds it
makes and to deprive those who need
subtitles from experiencing the visual
cues for the actual words and sounds
it's honestly a dick move but where were
you
it's not important if it's not important
why not tell me vituimo would be the
goodest Droid ever at TV since yes you
would oh yes he would also apparently
the slightly sad and malfunctioning
Droid with a stammer was only called B2
emo because available to buy online just
seemed a little too on the nose Marvel
said you were out ruining your health
and reputation with friends of low
character Facebook don't tell anybody
you saw me don't tell anybody you know
where I am
that's two lies that's technically zero
lies that's just not talking like for
instance if I just never said anything
about my bb-8 Ahsoka erotic time travel
fan fiction I'm not lying to you I'm
just uh
I mean sure it's beige and overcrowded
but it's no Tatooine where's my sand
Planet at walking through a crowded
thoroughfare that contains many
different alien species for all the
sometime in a Star Wars property cliche
then you remember you still had half a
bottle of milk stashed at home making up
your own story and selecting nog is the
alcoholic beverage of your own free will
you come when I woke up
you've come in now to apologize
this Cooperative fibbing scene is great
it builds character adds levity and
progresses the story wait am I starting
to like Star Wars again have you
modified your uniform perhaps lately
misunderstanding the literal definition
of the word uniform in this case appears
to Bear all the Hallmarks of what I like
to describe as regrettableness Adventure
title of my sex tape they're in the
brothel which we're not supposed to have
the expensive one which they shouldn't
be able to afford a drinking roof not
which we're not supposed to allow
is delightful in the scene this show may
actually be good and that's making my
job even more difficult so take this in
for making me work harder than a normal
show
fingering someone's lifter without
explicit consent also in the name of
Jabba's jiggly bits what the [ __ ] is he
playing at Andor is extremely fortunate
that this stunt didn't end an immediate
trip to the day since last accident
board what happened here
I fell on what a jealous husband
I have something to sell don't we all
having a character speak solely in witty
retorts AKA weedening so how it works
and bundle things before in my contacts
geez birth control in a galaxy far far
away sounds very complicated
this guy come from Scott to wean that's
right I'm sending the accents again you
know why because it makes no sense that
there's a dialect this specific that
exists a long long time ago and that the
ancestors of that dialect all just
happen to land in the same Northern
Territory of a tiny Island on a tiny
planet that is in a galaxy far far away
that's why are you
what
looks like it's turned into something
more than work what the hell is he
basing that on that'll seem very
business-like I mean unless I've
completely misinterpreted what a will
Bonnie run was referring to just promise
he knows nothing about any of this he'd
do anything for me yeah well I'd do
anything for a well-cooked cheeseburger
but that doesn't mean that the cows
should just trust me with their secret
plans for Galactic Rebellion I may be
mixing several bad metaphors there it's
good to see you Tim Star Wars pretends
adding an extra M to Tim makes it more
Galactic it does not
still have no idea what's going on here
but I'm confident enough to slap a kids
on it and move on why is that a DOT on
the map that is abstract and confusing
enough so that you can just conjure up a
plot moving clue and the audience will
go along with it seems when you take
orders from nurture don't accidentally
we said all our needs to do is stand
here
I want to vetch The Reluctant Bounty
Hunter series based on this line
delivery alone
on the TV since convenience scale I'd
rate this pastor by carrying a tall pile
of boxes that they can't see over
somewhere below a comically large pane
of glass being transported to a dumpster
but above a grand piano falling from a
crane
[Music]
do you must attack filter
you know it kind of puts a little spy
thing at risk when you have visible
reactions to the code words and such
sure the show needs us to know
something's up but the characters lives
are on the line if anyone notices
anything out of the ordinary so these
reactions are poor spycraft at best and
suicidal at worst Boodles this is the
murder of two premier employees wow
Cyril's discount Ramsay boldening so
hard here I would strongly suggest that
anyone who enjoys their genitalia
attached to their person should stop
arguing with him
name of trump is going out out there
trying to spend 20 minutes trying to
figure out what deity chob was in the
Star Wars Universe And as far as I can
tell they're just making up names at
this point with no actual reference and
if that's the case how am I supposed to
convert glad we're ending on this qunari
Lord of the Flies backstory emotional
beat without any context for where all
the adults went sure it might be
explained later but I demand answers now
where's Mama Cass episode does not
contain a k2so
oh no he died he died a new life awaits
have you been with us before no I've
worked a lot of women in my day you've
worked and then Jesse came back because
let me ask you a question bonehead why
are you trying to kill me
what what what sorry it works I've
bundle things before in my contacts
thanks come on
you need to be worrying about who's
gonna stick by your side yeah Stick by
Me Maybe it's good to see you Tim
greetings Tim the enchanter forward
forward
you shocked my battleship that he let
him talk you into this the subject is
money and just ask you a question what
since when you take orders from nurture
don't answer that you need work this bad
leave him out of it and yes
that is your hand and our way very good
I'll be back it is not gonna say that
did you